[Musique]
ils sont venus des quatre coins de la
france pour en découdre ce week-end dans
le berry durant deux jours plus de 200
joueurs se sont affrontés d'abord en
individuel puis ce dimanche par équipes
cette manche nouvellement inscrites au
calendrier compte pour les championnats
de france
souvent présent au fond des bars de
quartier le pool anglais est arrivée
d'angleterre il ya une trentaine
d'années plus qu'un loisir le billard
n'en reste pas moins un sport avec ses
poings et ses règles
la spécificité ben c'est que c'est assez
facile si vous voulez à comprendre le
jeu c'est que y'a 15 billes
il ya cette bible rouge 7 bis jaune et
l'habit noir
donc après la casse on détermine qui a
les rouges ou les jaunes et le but du
jeu c'est de rentrer les vies de sa
couleur sont déroulées sur les jaunes et
de rentrée noire en dernier et lorsqu'on
a rentré un noir en dernier on a gagné
la partie et pour être un bon joueur il
faut d'abord être un passionné comme
jean-michel 19 ans il pratique depuis
une dizaine d'années et évolué en
compétition officielle depuis six ans
mais pour arriver à un haut niveau la
passion ne suffit pas il faut tout de
même quelques qualités c'est plus un jeu
d'attentes de précision aussi su mine de
rien ça reste ça reste de l' en poche de
billets les calculs d'angle les
trajectoires qui vont être repéré
et aussi le fait d'être plutôt calme
calme bien résisté à la pression pour
cette épreuve berrichonne fini
l'ambiance sombre du bar pour le bon
déroulement c'est bien dans un gymnase
que le club castelroussin a fait livrer
les trente six tables de jeu les
gymnases dans ses pas là demain ce faire
d'un bar quand on accueille 36 milliard
voire plus c'est compliqué de les mettre
dans un bar ou dans une salle pour avoir
la place
comme vous le voyez derrière moi il ya
vraiment de l'espace entre les billards
les joueurs ne se gêne pas tous les
joueurs se sont déjà donné rendez vous
l'année prochaine pour une nouvelle
manche et pour les meilleurs d'entre eux
autre rendez-vous dans un mois lors des
championnats d'europe en irlande